in 1866 they never envisioned the world
in which we live in today where we have
a flood of illegal immigrants coming
mainly from our southern border the 14th
minute the Fourteenth Amendment has been
interpreted three times by our Supreme
Court to say that if you were born in
the United States even if you were here
in a legal status of your parents where
you're in a legal status you're
automatically entitled to citizenship
there are a lot of people who come to
this country for the very purpose of
having a child some break our law by
coming across the border in our border
states to go to American hospitals to
have a child so that child will become a
citizen having an anchor to the country
there are other people rich people
mainly from the Mideast in Asia who come
to America on tourist visas for the
purpose of having a child in an American
resort with a hospital to gain
citizenship I think those two ways of
conferring citizenship really undermine
the value of citizenships so I think
that's not an unreasonable request in a
prospective fashion to change the 14th
amendment by allowing the Congress to
set rules on citizenship and what I
would say is if you're students studying
here and you have a child they're
automatically a citizen if you're a
temporary worker you have a child you're
automatically a citizen in other words
if you're adding value to our country if
you have a good connection with America
then your child will be conferred
citizenship you would not be given
citizenship under my proposal if you're
just visiting the country as a tourist
and you would not be given citizenship
if you broke our law and had a child
here in an illegal status to me that
makes sense and I think that's a logical
way to move forward the American people
are looking for solutions to prevent the
third wave of illegal immigration Ronald
Reagan gave amnesty to 3 million now we
have 12 what I have to do to sell us in
South Carolina is prove the people of my
state we're not going to have a third
wave of legal immigration 20 years from
now that's why we need to look at the
14th amendment
I'm always open to making sure the
Constitution is make sense in the time
we live I'd like to have the balanced
budget amendment to the Constitution I'm
convinced that Republicans and Democrats
are not going to do the hard things to
balance our budget see no to different
groups
unless they a constitutional requirement
to balance the budget like most states
have so yes I think the Constitution's a
sacred document it's a governing
document